well Jennifer as per Jennifer she had
this enormous diamond ring
and so when she slapped me one of the
times it cut open across my eye my
eyebrow
so I just you know and she's never
apologized
Jane Fonda not letting this one go there
was one time she accidentally got me
with her diamond ring on my eyebrow and
that kind of hurt and we had to put a
little ice on it seems she still hung up
on what allegedly went down during this
scene between her and Jennifer Lopez in
the 2005 rom-com Monster-in-Law
stop
oh God this is crazy most of the time it
was fake
during Jane's appearance on the Drew
Barrymore show alongside guest Lily
Tomlin last week she reflects on behind
the scenes moments from some of her most
notable films take off that white dress
right now or I'll take it off for you
and shares the first thing that comes to
mind when thinking about Monster-in-Law
we have a slapping scene yeah
I slap her she slaps me I love her it's
the scene where her character Viola
shows up wearing white on the morning of
her son's wedding ceremony in Charlotte
the bride played by JLo is furious well
Jennifer as per Jennifer she had this
enormous diamond ring
and so when she slapped me one of the
times it cut open across my eye my
eyebrow
so I just you know and she's never
apologized
but Jennifer did react to it in 2019 on
her YouTube channel and a video called
making a scene episode one and I punched
her in the eye by mistake
right there
ouch the scene took on a life of its own
in a way that we never imagined I didn't
even think we were supposed to slap each
other I just remember afterwards Jane
had a a blood blister I was just I felt
I was like oh my God I'm so sorry and
she was like it's fine it's fine we want
to go to the freaking purple blister
that was sticking out
and she didn't care despite it all seems
there's no bad blood between Jane and
Jennifer I was a little nervous in the
beginning because I didn't know what to
expect I you know she could have been a
diva for all I knew I I was wondering
and um it was very it was easy she's
smart she's talented to me she's pretty
amazing Jane was front and center when
Jennifer was honored with a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame back in 2013.
most of these stars on this Hollywood
Walk of Fame are for a person that has
one Talent to tell you the truth she
should have an entire block
of stars while it's unclear if Jane will
move past the mishap fans can always
take a trip down memory lane
you know you learn how to you know turn
your head and then they add some sound
and but it was fun we had a good time we
laughed a lot
[Music]